marvel actress evangeline lilly is
speaking out against covet vaccine
mandates
in a message shared to instagram on
thursday the ant-man star reveals she
attended a controversial rally over the
weekend lily says quote i was in dc this
weekend to support bodily sovereignty
all of you in the crowd i thank you i
love you adding quote i believe nobody
should ever be forced to inject their
body with anything against their will
lily went on to condemn various threats
to those who choose not to be vaccinated
including reasons involving loss of
employment alienation from loved ones
and excommunication from society she
ended her caption with quote this is not
the way this is not safe this is not
healthy this is not love i understand
the world is in fear but i don't believe
that answering fear with force will fix
our problems it should be noted the cdc
recommends that all eligible people
receive their covet 19 vaccine and
serious adverse effects related to the
vaccine are exceedingly rare
robert kennedy jr sparked controversy on
sunday while speaking at the same event
where he compared vaccine mandates to
the holocaust and what do we do about
this
[Music]
what do we do
we resist
the nephew of john f kennedy has been an
outspoken critic of the covet 19 vaccine
actress cheryl hines took to twitter to
condemn her husband robert f kennedy
jr's comments she wrote in part quote
the atrocities that millions endured
during the holocaust should never be
compared to anyone or anything
his opinions are not a reflection of my
own
at the onset of the pandemic in march of
2020 lily sparked backlash for comments
she shared on instagram
lily revealed her family was not
quarantining at the time despite the
cdc's message to practice social
distancing in order to slow the spread
of the coronavirus
lily posted an apology to instagram days
later writing in part quote my direct
and special apologies to those most
affected by this pandemic
i didn't think i'd get caught you didn't
think about a lot of things lilly has
starred in three mcu blockbusters with a
fourth one on the way ant-man and the
wasp quantomania has wrapped filming
it's slated to be released next year
[Music]
you